dr anthony fauci says covet vaccinations
may be available to children under five
as soon as next month and it cannot
happen soon enough the numbers really
tell the story here on average in this
country about 900 children a day are
being admitted to hospitals with covid
carter evans is in kansas city missouri
where pants are where parents rather
facing very difficult choices carter
this is tough good morning to you
it is tough good morning gail the number
of kids with kovid being admitted here
to mercy children's hospital is hitting
all-time highs and with the large number
of kids still testing positive there are
concerns that this coven surge is not
yet over
at children's mercy hospital you got it
of the 33 kids admitted with covett
seven are in the icu
we have young children all the way down
to three months of age in the hospital
without any pre-existing condition dr
angela myers says the highly
transmissible omicron strain is mostly
infecting kids who are unvaccinated many
because they're too young children's
mercy tested more than 3 700 kids last
week and more than a third came back
positive the numbers correlate with the
state's low vaccination rate of just 22
percent for kids
should kids who are too young for
vaccines be masking up in school 100
percent kids should be masking in
schools but kovitt is now shutting down
schools in missouri this month alone 62
districts canceled classes because of
staff shortages the closures came after
several districts removed mass
requirements when the state attorney
general threatened to sue them and take
away their funding
the covet 19 virus remains a significant
threat but in kansas city mayor quinton
lucas is keeping masks in schools when
it comes to mask mandates how far are
you willing to take this
we've been sued in state and federal
courts we're willing to go all the way
to the supreme court his battle to keep
kids safe is deeply personal my
nine-month-old son came down with covet
it was heartbreaking i think it's my
role to make sure at least in my
community that we can keep people safe
and protect our children
and even when kids recover from covet
just sending them home from the hospital
can be a challenge according to dr alex
garza how do we send kids from our
nicu's home when their parents have
covet and we can't do that so there's
all these other social issues that are
really being amplified by covid
now when a vaccine is approved for kids
two to four years old according to dr
fauci it could take three doses to get
the full benefits and for now doctors
say the best way to protect children who
are too young for the vaccine
is to get vaccinated yourself
nate
carter thank you